he is a colleague of mine from NFL
Network and we always love chat and
football with him also a part of Roman
get Roman dot-com / coach will discuss
all of that with our friend brian
bellick how are you Brian
how you doing I am doing great what do
you think of this matchup I love it I'm
excited I do it I think I love it is the
ying and yang
you know we got to spread out offensive
the Kansas City Chiefs the great defense
of San Francisco it's old versus new
good versus bad cats versus dogs I think
living together in Miami that's what
they're doing right and again I want to
just pause on that for a second and kind
of go down the Wayback Machine with you
what advice would you give obviously
he's gonna get this advice from his dad
and he's been through it as an offensive
coordinator before what advice would you
give Kyle Shanahan going into his first
Super Bowl
based on your experience back in the day
in Tampa with the Ravens well the good
thing for Kyle's like you said he grew
up with I mean he said dinner every
night talking football with his dad and
has been through these so many times
because it because of his dad he's got a
lot of although I remember and you know
I obviously didn't have that experience
I remember you know number of coaches
reached out and I you know Dan Reeves
reached out to me that was great I had
played under Dan and and he sat and for
a good hour and a half
telling me about how to orchestrate the
week and what you needed to and then
what he got done he says well you know
what I haven't won one of these things
so just do the opposite thing I just
told you you know the biggest advice
that you get and it's and it's
legitimate is you basically have got to
use this week because of just the hectic
nature of what it is down at the Super
Bowl site you got to get everything in
you have to have the game plan and we
had our entire game plan in we could
have played that first Sunday of the bye
week by design and so you get it all in
and and of course the first part of the
week is all that you know you really
have to rely on your administrative
staff because you the tickets and the
cars and the flights and that you get
all that behind you you kind of mentally
get the game plan in so that when you
get
to the to the site itself now you just
have to kind of freshen it up and
practice is really kind of a relief
because it gets you away from the
badness that's going on it's the only
thing that feels normal to you during
the week of Super Bowl is actually being
out of practice what was the biggest
distraction you know we in the media
talked about distractions because we
actually like when something does come
up that we could bite into that maybe
we're a factor and everything what was
happening with your team at the time
drive well you know we had a pretty
experienced team and I'll say the league
actually does a pretty good job yeah
early on it's a little hectic but by the
time you get to Wednesday and really
start your preparation they dial it back
I was always more concerned and caution
them about look don't don't load too
much up on your own plate I mean all
these guys have their own radio and TV
deals and whatever and of course I
started the week out by accusing the a
you know the amassed media of being
ambulance chasers and you know so that
start the week out just right when I had
to do it the Ray Lewis situation and all
that right that kind of set a tone that
made it kind of interesting so how did
that work for you when you scroll them
ambulance chasers not real well other
than we kicked that you-know-what out of
your head we lost it would have not gone
well but I always had a dream I always
wished I could have got back to that
second Super Bowl because after I stood
up there and basically called them
ambulance chasers and that they weren't
qualified to do what they were doing and
whatever I was dying to the next the
next time I could get in that situation
to step into that news conference and
say and another thing yeah I guess
because again coaches will will try and
I guess put some sort of firewall around
their team I don't know obviously I
don't think either one of these teams
have to do that I do remember
when I was covering the Super Bowl the
another Super Bowl in Tampa between the
Steelers and the and the Cardinals that
Ken Whisenhunt was full-on employing the
nobody believes in his card I mean just
he was a player he was dealing that card
into basically everybody like he he was
somebody like handing out business cards
it's some sort of
like here here's my and nobody believes
in this card and almost works right you
know I mean us against the world and
yeah you're right I don't think these
two teams both are so so strong and what
they do although the style is certainly
different and it'd be hard for the coach
to get up there and played that card
because obviously Kansas City is so
highly thought of and certainly San
Francisco and everything but they're
doing they'll find something else to
feel disrespected Brian Billick here on
the Rich Eisen show Andy Reed I'm not
gonna tell any tales out of school is
I'm gonna give the top ten storylines
that fans could expect for the week he's
going to be way way up there what he
thinks going on between his temples
right now Brian you know and obviously
you're not going to get a hint of it
because Andy is so subdued any and our
classmates come back into BYU days right
Andy I just you're so happy for Andy
after an incredible career to finally
get an opportunity if he can indeed and
he's obviously gonna hold that at arm's
length it's just something you just
don't let yourself go there particularly
Andy at this stage in his career and you
know I don't know how many more here's
Andy sky coach but as you always hear
you know you can you never know when
you're going to get back and it's been
what 15 years since he was on his first
one so yeah I can't imagine he's just
not gonna let him go let himself go
there emotionally until after the game
well I mean I think you know what keeps
your coach younger is having someone
like mahomes to coach right and what a
spectacular talent and I and and Andy
has had you're right what how much fun
is it now to kind of tap into a whole
nother vein of offense and what you do
for this guy who's just so spectacular
and all the things that he can do well
you know I'm trying to hold myself back
from going here just yet cuz there's
still so much time between now and kick
but it's difficult for me to not think
that this is mahomes moment that this is
it it's his first time in the Superbowl
and I know we've seen before first time
super I mean Marina went once never got
back I get it
I just have a feeling like we're about
to see even against the defense that
that that would allow him to burnish
this this reputation this new one would
say legacy that this is a legacy
potential birth for him I'm wondering
what you think Brian yeah that catapult
to obviously what he has done to this
point he has a solid footing for a
potential Hall of Fame career now we got
a long way to go he's very very young
obviously and and still has to follow up
with it stay healthy and the like but
just the example you gave Dan Marino
being in that same well we're gonna be
back to a bunch of these well you just
don't know that it's gonna be and
obviously we're going to talk about it
forever this week and the next week I'm
gonna go up two films and do my playbook
segments this week and it's been fun
crawling back through the film obviously
with the Kansas City it's all about
there are just so many weapons and no
matter what you do okay you double hill
and you double Kelsey alright well that
still leaves some pretty good guys in
Hardman and Robinson and Watkins one on
one that can leave you vulnerable if you
think you're going to get home with just
a three or four man rush and now like we
saw against Tennessee
mahomes decides to pull it down and
break the edge and I mean there's just
so many ways to get beat but San
Francisco I mean how impressive was that
done a championship game and throw the
ball only eight times to run the ball
that well that was just stunning yeah
Brian Billick here on the Rich Eisen
show yesterday I made the analogy it was
like a five-year-old and an elevator
pressing the same button over and over
and over no freaking because they just
enjoy watching it light up and then just
keep pressing the button that's the way
Kyle Shanahan was with most hurt and the
run I guess when you see it's working
how do you snot stop pushing that button
right you don't and I give them credit
of course this is in in in inherent to
what they do their commitment to the run
because there's times you'll talk to
yourself out of the coach you know
you've got something going and and you
say and you start to think well you know
I have coached all the time go well now
let's stay away from the inside zone
because because we're cashed it once it
and they got to start adjust and that's
like well how about we let's see if they
really do it just okay
how about
we keep running those plays until they
show us they can actually stop it and
Green Bay absolutely didn't matter what
they did how what the number count was
who they dropped down there was like
nothing they could do but I will say
this and and Shawn O'Hara and I were
talking about this because when you go
back the first thing that came to mind
to me of this matchup was the 2007 Super
Bowl of New England and the New York
Giants New England was number one on
offense and explosive plays it was brady
and moss and watson and bulk all that
whole group and then and who came in new
york with that four-man rush yep and
what that allowed them to do the back
end and an interesting side note how
about that the architect of that defense
that won the Super Bowl for the Giants
Steve Spagnola is now the defensive
coordinator for the Kansas City Chiefs
how about that conversation Andy walking
into Spagnola
office going hey remember what you did
what do you think they're going to try
to do to us what page are they going to
pull with that great four-man rush that
San Francisco has won't be ready for it
it'd be a great conversation yeah but I
mean obviously mahomes is a different
quarterback than Brady but the analogy
is without question there and obviously
you know the the issue to me and having
seen it's an amazing that they held
Henry less than 100 yards and you think
and they did great against the run that
that they should be better
the Chiefs defense against the run for
San Francisco right and to me this game
Brian Billick comes down to can that
defensive line that you point out that
comes in to put just four sets of hands
in the dirt you have to scheme your way
that that they do get the pressure on
the homes and win this football game and
and set the edgeware mahomes can't gain
the edge that to me is the win loss of
Super Bowl 54 I wonder what you think
and all and the hard part will be for
that four-man rush and I'm doing again
on PlayBook a segment to show it that
the hard thing is you can't you can't be
the hard chart you know we're gonna get
a sack that's not what's gonna win the
game for you if you stick to that
four-man rush and they're you know you
got talking about five first round draft
choices on the defensive line they can
wrote
guys through it's going to be a good
matchup but you've got to maintain
contain and you got to fill you got a
mush rush you know there's a couple
instance I'm showing where both sit
comes around the edge and and you know
can be spectacular but if you open up
that gap between you the defensive
tackle we saw it against Tennessee or
mahomes will just step up between the
two get to the outside either fire the
60-yard touchdown down the field or pull
the ball down and run so that four-man
rush
can't be an all-out let's get to the
quarterback as much as it let's just
keep them as tight as we can in the
pocket yes he can beat us from there but
we know what he's gonna do if he gets
outside Brian Billick here on the Rich
Eisen show what is Roman what are you
doing with Roman Brian what's that about
you know what it's been fun to watch how
people become more more aware of get
Roman calm you know when you get older
like you and I rich like you and I you
know against that's going on you know
and you need to take you you don't need
you don't go to the doctor enough when
you do go it takes a month to get in
there I don't care what CD hair-loss
cold sores whatever in the privacy of
your own home you get online get Roman
comm us license position at most point
importantly you can get the
pharmaceuticals that you're guaranteed
the amount of counterfeit
pharmaceuticals out there is stunning to
me you go to get Roman comm you get the
help from us licensed physician and you
get the right pharmaceuticals for it if
you need to last things for you Brian do
you have a prediction on the game were
you reserving that what he got for me
boy you know it this one yeah I don't
know how you don't go with Kansas City
but like that New York game and the
Giants game this is a unique matchup
that yeah it's going to be hard and I
was kidding with the guys the other day
I've got I've got a book written by
Knute Rockne in 1934 and no he didn't
give it to me personally but it is a
book that says if you've got to be good
on one side of the ball together be good
on offense because you're never out of
it and that's clear the thing for me was
Kansas City no matter how the game goes
even if the turnovers and whatever and
San Francisco is running the ball like
they did against the Packers Kansas City
just never feels like they're out of it
that's all hard to overcome okay and do
you remember the first time you met Reed
you got that story
when do when did you actually meet him
oh well he was he was an offensive
lineman I was said he was a little
younger than I was right and it was
actually I came back coach the JV team
now I can't you know Andy and I didn't
really in her I didn't know each other
that well it was more post that that we
were both you are you grads and had done
some things but yeah Andy's the real
deal you know he's just as good and what
you see people got to know what you see
in the news conference that subtle
subdued kind of mumbling that's Andy
that's Andy's that's no laughs that's
handy so when he says he had a
cheeseburger and went to sleep to
celebrate the AFC channel ID there is
that it was one cheeseburger promise you
that was jim mcmahon the quarterback
when you were the grad assistant was he
there he was he was yeah jim was uh and
we had Steve Young you know that whole
progression who they're just Jeff Jim
was with the varsity and just tearing
things up when I was the JV coach there
I had a young early Steve Young and some
thanks Sosa it was a hell of a team so
Steve Young and McMahon and Andy Reed
were all at BYU kinda at the same time
that you were there so yeah and all it
all kind of flows through that and it
was kind of would you look back on it
and the grunt that kind of Mark Wilson
was was was a guy as well in there and
then and of course to have Jim I had gym
for your in Minnesota later on which was
a real gem because real deal now he's a
different some of the sideline
conversations with Jim Wright in itself
which would sell some books Brian take
care of yourself thanks to the time all
right we'll see you down in Miami at
coach Billick Brian Billick Super Bowl
winning head coach my compadre on
playbook on NFL Network great show
shot NFL Films for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
under wreck TV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app